it's going to be an anxious two-week
wait for some British holiday makers who
booked through Thomas cook turkey is one
of the most popular destinations but
even with its gorgeous scenery and
beaches the 20,000 plus tourists now
trapped here just want answers tomorrow
she's got a party on Sunday I'm go back
to work on Saturday and I need to get
home you know when you book a holiday
they say to you oh you can't go wrong
with the Thomas Cook holiday is kind of
thing you're booking with the secure
really and they do need to back small
companies and big companies and it shows
across across the border you know it's
been since like Woolworths went bust and
it's been getting worse and worse and
worse
all the way and that Thomas Cook I mean
I never ever thought Thomas got there
busting Britain's biggest peacetime
repatriation has swung into operation
they're organizing squadrons of
government chartered aircraft to fly
back a hundred and fifty thousand
thomascook travelers dotted around the
world it's stressful definitely is
or just she's ready for sleep for now so
there's gonna be a screaming match I
know until we get through here the
entire Thomas Cook fleet has now been
grounded this was the last of them
arriving back from Florida to Manchester
hours after the collapse was confirmed
it was quite emotional the staff didn't
really know what was happening told you
landed him crying this staff were very
emotional were they yeah we gave them a
round of applause we've got a few times
yeah before we landed so but I really
felt for the crew to be honest but they
were very dignified weren't they the
subtleness of the collapse has thrown
the travel industry into collective
anxiety with businesses worried whether
they're going to get paid and travellers
who've already paid caught in the middle
one couple and their baby were locked
out of their hotel room in Majorca
through Thomas cook that he would not
allow us back into our rooms until we
had paid the full amount of our holiday
he wouldn't let me in the room until I
basically cried and said what you want
me to do of my baby then the Turkish
government has threatened to prosecute
any hotel 'ya who throws out any Thomas
Cook traveler but it means many of the
smaller establishments will go to the
wall - we asked from Great Britain
government that they should find this
solution because millions of people's
affected from this situation not only in
Turkey Greece Spain and all all the
other destination also because most of
the labels noise desperate they don't
know when they get there seven
recriminations are already piling in a
plenty over what went wrong and the
collapse of such an established and
prestigious company is likely to have a
long lasting effect not just on jobs not
just on the tourist industry in Britain
and abroad but also on the price of
holidays but right now the thousands
still abroad and those who've seen their
holidays ditched are asking whether more
could have been done to save the world's
oldest travel company Alex Crawford Sky
News southern Turkey